welcome everybody to gamespot's day two
of the play for all charity stream and
it is my pleasure to be joined by
lucy james hello and
most importantly it's the kind of funny
crew we've got
greg miller hello team blessing
yo yay junior hello tam
and snow bike mike
hello tam how are you guys doing
we're good tim you like that you're not
very good good good this is this again
we're really a bit creepy now
now we're taking it too far i feel like
this is what happens when like you're
you're like
you all know that i'm about to be killed
but you're just trying yeah
like you're like what's the point this
guy's got not not a lot of time left to
live
so from behind me like nick's going to
appear with a knife and stab me in the
back
of course we are raising money for
ablegamers a wow
someone absolutely clocked me there um
ablegame is a charity that provides
opportunities and uh to to make games
inclusive for those that have
disabilities
um this would be much easier if you
weren't all
attacking me with a ball at the same
time
get used to this so uh long story short
we're trying to raise
uh 30k by the end of the week which is a
tall order we know but we thought shoot
for this guy
shoot for the moon um and uh yeah we're
gonna
we're gonna play uh a bit of knockout ce
which is a lot of fun
and while you're watching and enjoying
the entertainment you can go to
tinyurl.com
play for all 20 21 and uh donate
please donate generously if you are in a
position to and uh
spread the word let people know that
you're watching and this is happening
and maybe your
your tweet or your your facebook message
or whatever it may be a text message
whatsapp might pass the eyes of someone
who's
filthy rich a whale as they call it in
the industry
um and we're like mobile game when a
mobile game will
be like yo don't buy one of these
in-game app purchases and instead donate
that one million dollars to this charity
um so yeah let's play some video games
let's do it guys yeah let's do it uh
what is it street play is that what we
do yeah
private match replay all right
eventually if you want if
if you ever want to sit out to him since
you're driving you could do like uh
spectate right yeah right mike can he
speculate
he can't spectate
everybody remember it is the heat wave
has kicked off today there's new stuff
in the
shop i'm getting these these
window wiper glasses i'll tell you what
oh greg i want to be the guy in the tube
just having fun enjoying the summer sun
but i need to go collect those popsicles
you know what i mean we got to collect
those popsicles you and i this is
competitive
what this game is asking me to buy the
standard edition but i own the standard
edition
what is it doing here we go sam here we
go
gamespot doesn't know how to use oh my
god i mean
again becoming a theme of uh why don't
we just play some
how do you even start a new game can i
just promote one of you guys to leaders
and you can start it yeah probably how
do i do that
yeah that should work
uh if you go to if you press options
press
triangle i don't know what controller
you're playing on or for options
triangle yeah
it should bring up your group and i'm
sure if you click one of us it might
give you the option to promote
it doesn't oh you still like mike's in
charge right
oh yeah it's not like mike is in charge
that's what's sweet okay let's do it
y'all
i don't know how that happened oh that
wasn't are you bouncing
oh when i got
so i don't know if it's i don't know how
i know we're all very busy
e3 everything else it needs to be
discussed at the start of this that
blessing is god tier
is he has he been prepped there was a
time where we were
we were all good i don't know where my
skill level is but blessing what are
your ranks right now
uh right now in team ko i am platinum
ranked
uh whoa solo i am sapphire is this why
you want me
is this why you won't play valerie i
wasn't ranking until i got there
this is why you don't play violin with
me oh yeah i've been hooked on knockout
city
like i've been just i've been in about
um i want to say 45 hours
at least in knockout city i haven't
checked in a couple days
so one of our team members here is
currently on a
free play membership and is not allowed
to join a
is that me it's got to be tammy
i can't cancel i didn't mean to do that
tam are you sure you're logged into the
right account
100 i literally paid money for this
moments ago
okay okay don't take it out on me we're
taking out and kind of funny that game
spark
promote you tim tim give it a try see
what happens on your ends
okay i'll hit play private match
he's telling me to buy the standard
edition of the game
well what happens when you click the
button
stop chasing me blessing all right it
takes me to find them don't chase me
oh my god i'm gonna i'm gonna cut to the
uh loop for a second so it doesn't show
my
credit card details you don't want to
pull yourself
did anyone hear it i heard it no okay
we heard it yeah we know you're good
go great it's going great okay i have
the game now
do i need to please stop pissing with me
ea are you sure you have the game
are you sure you have purchased the game
i've purchased this game three times in
the last 10 hours
on steam yeah unbelievable all right all
right what do you have against
supporting ea
all they've done is give and give you
you don't want to give them the measly
20 bucks in the cost to play this game
all right what what what version are we
doing 3v3 team ko
oh what are we doing here can i be on
blessings team
no no that's not how it works i'm on
blessings game it's just me and blessing
i don't even know how we have five
people right yeah
will it let us do 3v3 with like a rando
i've not tried that
uh if you're going to a private match
you
we won't have a rando at all but uh
yeah we can we can have one spectator
yeah how do i
2v2 on one spectate we'll do that yeah
cool okay so do that does spectating
only work on private or if we wanted to
go like
uh play play how do i only private
how do i select that i'm a spectator oh
well i just automatically do it because
you're ef5 we'll see
you know just don't choose the size i
don't have sides
sick and lucy sick dragon mike
i get to be an esports cluster ladies
and gentlemen welcome to the first
of many kind of funny and games for
collaborations for
knockout city the teams today are paused
for impact
and for information
okay well we will figure out where the
teams are we've got a bomb
for you no no no no no no no no no we
got lucy
and blessing blessing talking up a big
game right now
greg and snow bike mike both
seasoned gamers who will come out on top
let's find out
good movement here by mike and and greg
just practicing from passing
right across the way okay we've got greg
taking up a defensive position
very very smart maneuver here by greg
we've got a battle happening in the
middle of the map here
between lucy figuring out the buttons
again
do you think me and mike
oh got out of here there we go
great catch by mike there can you return
it
oh mike's no sludge and he's throwing
the bomb back
i have exploded early narrow miss there
from mike
coming greg lucy dizzing yourself there
oh no i'm sorry blessing i failed you
oh it's chaos it's chaos right in the
middle great throw by lucy there
go greg oh too busy celebrating
got a dodge ball to the back of the head
from snow bike mic you truly hate to see
it
oh one maneuver there from blessing
wasting no time and throwing the ball
back
i'm coming blast
the fake out from me uh
i did bomb you yes oh okay mike
from across the map lobbing it snowback
michael with the amazing love
body channel there you go oh i'm here
with you wow
great pass there we go one more one here
greg
i'm down
everything's like coming back and i say
coming back i've literally played it
once
but i've had a fun time like riding a
bike loose like riding a bike
oh narrowly avoided getting blown up
there lucy
thank you they're on the bridge they're
on the bridge
wow what a long range throw from
blessing there
there you go way to get out of there
let's see using cover to spin his ball
around
impressive
guys beautiful too many of you
oh no i'm sorry
oh tricky maneuvers there from mike
it's about to float i tried to go for
the mario stomp on the head
are you gonna get it i like that oh
buddy check from mike
oh well we got him off greg i think we
started him off
nice oh you did oh no he blew me up
greg's got it greg's got it oh
we're good now we stick together we play
our game
yeah they're coming yeah
wow an instant throwback from blessing
he loves that move it's the only one i
have
job greg i'm right behind you everywhere
you let's bring
wow beautiful work beautiful work lucy
okay first win goes to lucy and
blessing uh we had a couple donations uh
ten dollars from matt hawking
thank you so much it says bring back
super dodgeball for the nes
oh yeah finesse um oh wait are we
playing oh no we are yeah we're in we're
in
uh not tamora gives twenty dollars and
says classic to more shenanigans
keeps me coming back every year no i
don't know who not tomorrow is but
they genuinely do come back every year i
love her
lucy just walking straight off the
building you love to see it
uh noah's iqbal uh with five dollars uh
thank you uh i i remember reading the
names matt hawking
and now us every year um whenever we we
stream stuff and raise money so
thank you stop it a lot of erratic
movements on blessings camera here
oh he's got his sensitivity way up
well that's how you know he's a real
gamer he's a pro gamer i can't watch his
camera for too long
really for knockout sees my sensitivity
oh blessing a heavy has got a very
specific strategy and i like it
greg his return on balls is
i can't i can't analyze too many of
anyone's plays otherwise it gives it
away to the other team
oh good playing mike that was close
good job greg i'm back with you
big rush down strategy from blessing
right now i'm hockey chat
tim buying this game three times
what a catch from greg there
oh what a dodge and then following up
with the body check
yeah oh
wow it's good yeah i respect that nice
greg man the spectator is working out
well huh
it's good yeah what the hell tam
oh lucy pulling maneuvers lucy pulling
maneuvers
oh nice job wasn't it me what was it
what did i do no she's uh she didn't
except she did great
she did a great infiltration snuck
behind and then realized she doesn't
have a ball
yeah but then blessing you one yeah oh
that was amazing
you're scared i can tell you what
craig's doing let's follow craig
i'm right next to greg you're okay i'm
still scared
let's play sea of thieves
come back work by a body check
and then straight into the ball throw
one one
even scores all right lucy i'm gonna
start sticking closer to you i'm gonna
pass back and forth we're gonna have a
good
teamwork momentum all right you and me
we got this we got this we've got this
we've got this okay all right
here it is the final round plateau
down to this i'm right behind gold for
bro
they're up there oh yeah they're to the
right throw me first then grab that
god [ __ ] nice guy oh no the oh
oh bold play by greg picking up the bomb
couldn't get rid of it quick enough
good good catch thank you
good throw by lucy delayed the throw
and got there uh plus i got a bomb
oh wait let's go don't donate me first
i got your back i got your back oh
wow blessing ko in a sandwich of dodge
balls
stuck between a rock and a hard place
all right lucy hang in there
hang in there lucy yeah he's trying to
poop me off the edge
i'm going away mike's got a bomb get out
of there
impressive work from mike there oh no
over committed icarus flying too close
to the sun
and now we get to watch his untimely
demise
don't forget to get your kind of funny
logo all right it's up on our site
okay yeah maybe this might be the dream
team i can already tell okay we'll be
sapphire
i'll be sapphire before the end of the
night you might be back in bronze
frank's behind greg behind oh he got me
interesting throw there by mike
shut down oh good try greg
we've got two 2v1 situation here oh
come back come back great body check by
mike
oh blessing on point with the catches
he's catching it he's catching it
he's the net dude he doesn't want to go
past him he's got it one more point
mike and greg cannot take any losses
here otherwise it's over
blessing is really just going he's going
semi-automatic with the throws
getting very aggressive maneuvering how
do you jump up here
oh good work you said
fantastic timing fantastic timing
winners lucy and blessing great work
it was good it looked like good job it
looked like blessing was going to carry
it but lucy definitely carrying her own
weight
was hanging in there last thing is still
yeah oh my god
your emotes are perfect as well thank
you thank you
should we mix mix things up if we
rematch we can mix things up tim will
get through and i can spectate this next
game
okay make sure you're playing hell yeah
everybody touch the ball um
wait do i have to you got ready up
do i
you know on their on their squad the
highest amount of chaos they got was
greg with 11.
and you hit 11 also and so nice
you could have the mvp of our squad you
could have been mvp you're just you're
just as good as their best player
uh we got a couple more donations uh mad
exposure gave ten dollars with good game
all round
thanks so much uh mavs ally with fifty
dollars
holy [ __ ] thank you so much uh and jacob
mccourt uh
friend of the show with five dollars
thank you mate uh jacob also
uh wholesome jacob in our um
discord are we doing the same team oh no
oh no we got we got hammond
yeah um uh in our discord
and he said uh in chat lucy esports
james
uh i'm gonna need a better pronunciation
james esport games
yeah lucy james e games
uh it's a chat i'm very i can't wait
for your suggestions please uh
which i think like what like because
those pro teams are called like what
team liquids yeah
cloud9 ninjas in pajamas i need like
i need i need an esport name
ah oh damn close i hate to see it
he's so good he's been putting his time
in
you can see it you can see it in in merc
city dude ever since i got beat by the
one dev
i've been trying to make my wife his
name was merc
my merc yeah exactly i got married by
merc and ever since then i've not been
the same
this is like like when you get it's like
when you get rejected by your high
school crush and then you start working
out and you're like one day i'm gonna
see you again and you're gonna you're
gonna regret
you're turning me down oh good double
throw
oh where you running where are you
running mixed business uk
away from you yeah i'm right here right
here with you if it was greg
where is he
[Laughter]
i wish it would tell you which direction
you are being able to
it does around the side of the thing it
does what does it
yeah where are you i went through it you
see it and like see how there's like the
red
the like uh yeah like if you turn around
okay okay okay so there is a little bit
more um
then i then i thought okay
oh i'm sorry blessing i'm
we're still in this
[Music]
oh my god i just went into what the hell
oh where the hell am i
what is going on here i've joined the
battle my friend you're in it now
you're in the brawl oh my god that's
freaking go
blessings let's freaking go i will got
sucked into a tube yeah
i came out you said i was like what the
hell is going on
this game of the year it's a great sorry
ratchet that's so much fun
uh jason andrew and chad said no ellen
lucy james
i like that i like that
it's okay
oh what
oh
there you go
oh good throw
oh
uh jordan remay says uh bless you
clearly haven't played chicory yet if
this is a game of the year
dude i literally just started chicory
this morning
i haven't i it's on my list like i saw a
bunch of people talking about it
around e3 oh um
but between that and dufferin uh
right bless i've got i've got
do you want it i know it's all you saw
you
good throws damn yes
oh okay so
i think i have to stay a spectator
because my my computer
can't handle playing it like freezes
every time someone throws a ball
yeah like it freezes every time someone
throws a ball so i can't really
catch timing i mean
i'll suffer through it but don't expect
me to be very good
do whatever i have to do uh okay wait
we've had some great name suggestions uh
lebron james that's pretty good oh
that's good let's get it
juicy games um that's a bit weird
i don't know i've heard it before i like
it
um and then yeah jay
uh in youtube chat says timor's turning
up now
i'll swap out i can swap out
get mic back in
yeah how do we what team ah all right so
you stay right in the middle oh okay
we're switching them down
okay okay this is the question of how
fast can you beat us
i didn't even know that was possible
yeah i think we did it against uh merc
the dev of one time
and i believe they still won they did
not go well
round one here
that was rude you saw me passing to lucy
you hit me from behind all right what we
got here
i got greg
oh unlucky
[Music]
oh my god blessings
immediate throwback strategy is very
good yeah
well he gets it he catches it perfectly
every time so yeah
wow greg that was you had like three
balls coming at you then you caught all
of them hey man
i'm i at one point i was a contender you
know what i mean i was a medium of the
pack
maybe high meeting high points oh mike
again i'm playing games lucy nice
lucy jen misses you i missed
okay the fake out got lucy caught us
slipping
oh yeah great catch by michael
are you again greg surviving as well
one heart down
oh there's a train
waiting nice hot something can't lose
just say it's just body checking
happening over here
oh come on stop faking out oh get tired
oh lucy throws the ball hits the
blessing but then gets body checked
and
moral victory at one point we'll take it
yeah uh my
mouse ali says that new nickname for
blessing the ball whisperer
oh ball handler i'm happy about that one
i love that one i think we've gotta go
with ball handler yeah
yeah though throw me some more
suggestions that's the that's the chat's
task come up with esports names for
everyone
oh lucy just in the kill zone just
getting destroyed
okay oh slow ball did not work against
blessing i think knows it
he's seen this trick too many times plus
he knows everything is just like
fake out more like fake house city
bless i see you all the time playing
with uh danny and rick danny from
gamertag
yeah are are they as good as you are
they as committed to it know
uh no but like they're getting there
the more i play with them the more
they're they're starting to get up
they're also gold ranked
yeah in rank
it's just blessing give it a little
thing where at the end of each match i'm
usually the one with the most
sure just play valor with me oh
damn how do i get you fully in on
knockout city
we've got
he needs the game yeah i need to buy the
game one more time
i gotta buy the game one more time i got
only on every platform
he's the knockout say collector
just cut to lucy as she's soaring for
this guys
oh wow i was slightly distracted there
because someone rang me
and it came through my laptop and i was
very confused
oh blessing
i'm sorry we had to do it blessing him
mike win a again you'd love to see it
uh brandon hernandez asked who's better
blessing or barrett
well that's great that's what i would
play in a while i would love to
to play barrett again
i love bear but i mean like and i and
barrett's excellent of this game but i
mean blessing is
sapphire we're gonna sit here and ignore
this are we are we ignore the work this
man has put into this yeah
the rankings are official
i know the last time i checked with
barrett was probably like a week and a
half
ago or so so i'd have to check in to see
how much how much he's been playing this
game since then
greg can you just show up if he's been
in the lab can you just please donate
into the microphone
when you're ready everyone please donate
remember we're raising money for able
gamers and if you're like me you hate
steve spawn but it's a great
organization outside of him
so you should still probably make a
donation what's the url to donate it is
tinyurl.complayforall2021. thank you
greg
oh you're welcome everybody there we got
greg and i versus snowback mike and lucy
james
let's do it i want you i thought you
should have greg iverson
i'd be able to do that oh yeah
oh yeah i'd be smart too oh
noah clay in chat says uh lucy when do
you think the great british game of
bench ball will get a game
do have any of you heard of bench ball
no no it is it is the most british thing
where they take an american thing and
make it lamer
that's netball no but it's literally
isn't bench well they got the rules
wrong
isn't bench ball just dodge ball with a
bench in the middle
um i don't even remember the rules i
will i want to google them after because
hearing hearing the word benjamin has
unlocked something in me
i'm pretty sure you're all a blessing
i'm pretty sure bench ball is just
dodgeball by the bench in the middle to
act as like the imaginary line
throw the ball around the bench yeah i
don't know mike
i don't know mike you don't know i'm
when it convenience me i just say i'm
not brave from pakistani
oh okay in this scenario
nationally i'm like no i'm pakistani man
but when the good [ __ ] is happening i'll
be like yeah i'm british
great british break off couldn't be more
prouder about that ah
part of that greg you caught that
i got it you know what i mean you
remember do you remember the
the pivotal film hook when peter pan
came back to neverland right need to
learn that's where i'm at i got to learn
how to crow again boys
great job thereby expecting more support
no hook references but all right
all right i'll shake it off i'm sorry
i'm gonna save that for tomorrow
yeah i don't remember hook
watching anime yeah
yeah we're just watching evangelion
leave me alone
yeah what you've been watching what have
i been watching
uh i've been rewatching berserk
which is you know sorry again i was in
it i was in the game i was uh i'm
re-watching berserk
oh berserk i've heard so much about
berserk but i've never actually given it
a shot
it's basically the manga and the anime
that inspired dark souls so
very unbrand funny that's the one with
the big sword right mr big sword
bring me a dream bum bum bum
yeah oh
wasted bandwidth says uh carrie fisher
and george lucas have secret cameos in
hook i don't know that i [ __ ] say in
berserk i was trying to say what
uh yeah they're dark souls
i mean they could be on dark souls i
mean oh my god who knows
i bless it dang it
love you mike i don't know how to catch
those i've never figured that out a
blessing
greg's got a great strategy going here
with a sniper ball and also by getting
hit by vehicles to move him out of the
way
[Laughter]
i'll move by the vehicle strategically
getting hit by the car uh
wait no noah's put the rules for bench
ball in chat oh
i will read them out after this round
because they are suitably
british they have a big question for all
you out there in the chat and answers
too
can i get the trophy for riding around
this map in the private match you can
only do that in public
thank you someone in chat please please
get greg the information he needs
nice job lucy
i love snowback mike's outfit it's so
cool
in person or in-game i mean in-game man
but also in person yeah
in-game looks like he's dressed for like
snowboarding
i i'm always impressed they got some
great customization options yeah and
um so bench ball is where there's a
bench on both sides of the court
and you have a ball and you throw it at
your teammates
on the bench and if they catch it you
join them
everybody that's that's great nobody
cares
cinematic gaming media in the chat says
yes you can so i'm gonna ask everybody
not to hit me as i ride around in this
police car until i pop this
okay we are now going to hello you're
all my friends this doesn't matter
everyone everyone worried about everyone
just hop on a car let's just do one
round for trophies
don't break the trees don't break the
truth
don't break the truth everyone behaving
there's nobody mike moving around doing
fakeouts being menacing
lucy's being choked lucy threw her balls
so she's defenseless
how do you do a fake out oh uh r3
right is that the same one whatever they
say like xbox
i call it right stick i think it's r3
traditionally but i still call it the
right stick
greg interesting choice of car to jump
on he's riding on top of the police car
which is a big big ball of moves from
greg
dangerously close to the edge though
looks like he could fall off
there we go
have we been misled psn profiles game
over gregory knockouts
i think we've been misled we've been
missing out someone in chat is just
laughing their ass off just being like
look at these idiots
just riding around someone's gonna go
circling knockout roundabout ride a car
all the way around
surely they wouldn't allow that to
happen in private i'm gonna see another
hood maybe nina i'll get off i'll go to
this blue car
oh i get hit by the blue car hold on
we'll sit i've rode around
the table
maybe you'll have maybe a little pop at
the end of the match perhaps
maybe oh wait i mean cinematic gaming
media
first of all said yes you can and then
they've said yeah sorry lol
so oh come on absolutely done us there
absolutely done us there he's done us in
there
fair play all gamers doesn't get its
charity goals yeah
remember that everyone blames cinema at
gaming
a gaming media a whole media corporation
devoted to cinematic media just
misleading
us
oh nice loose knee
where is he though where is he
oh
there we have blessings crumpled body
lying in the middle of the road you hate
to see it
you hate to see it greg with the sniper
ball throwing it directly at that track
see
oh wow i don't know which one of you got
it
congratulations taken from the rooftops
greg that was greg a little patty in
between two
dodgeball buns there yeah there we go
loose can you mod me in the uh uh
twitch.tv slash game sport chat
can i mod you um you wanna ban cinematic
gaming meeting
no no it's noah clay 14 who says maybe
greg should do it in a public game and
not be a coward
no one needs to be timed out to think
about what's happening all right
noah congrats on being made a mod of the
gamespot chat
um it's it's funny that you said that
because i literally don't know how to do
it i don't know i don't trust them
i know how to do it but uh i see him i
see
i can't switch great throw and catch
there by snowback mike
interesting gears of war strategy here
using the high cover
and just reaching over and trying oh
blessing trying the up and around
strategy
lucy got hit by a car and then a
dodgeball
blessing meanwhile just staying silent
entirely focused on the game
this man is yeah oh my gosh we're out of
time
the car strategy uh screwed us we had
fun out there we had fun out there you
know you had a nice tour
there's three rounds we can still come
back
look people people in the chat are
asking uh on youtube chat are asking
about bench ball
so it's not just me who wants to know
more okay i just remember
i just remember playing it when i was a
kid um
in favor of non-contact sports like
actual dodgeball
so do your team sit on the opposite side
to where you are
i don't remember
oh gotta have that pass you got that oh
my god
warm it up oh my god lucy's head
bouncing off concrete there that was
brutal i was thinking of bench ball
my head was in the bench ball game oh my
god
that's played enough to get like a weird
like futuristic beetle glider thing
going on here
blessing is a sweaty knockout city
player
i mean this man this man is putting too
many hours already
based on blessings loadout and
customization i think there needs to be
an intervention
there might be honestly this is this
game has kept me from playing other
notable games like
day's gone yeah
massive mass effect andromeda
battlefield uh the one way of the police
mike nice
hard line yeah yeah i'm sorry
again i think every death has been me no
i just realized
you could pop out with your hard line
and i'm like man that came out that
really came out like ea was like we're
definitely putting this out fake out
blessing
oh no so what what other
what other sport unconventional sport
would you like to be made
into a game like this
well you know there's and ball and
there's lacrosse
pickleball um which rugby which one is
handmade
ones could we get in here handball is uh
a video game you could buy on the xbox
store
that was the power of friendship right
there that was powerful
so this there's a game that we used to
play in school called slap ball
which i don't know if there's an
equivalent that seems like a name that
only our school called it
but you basically it was like um you had
a tennis ball and there was a wall and
you would have to like
basically play ping-pong against the
wall but you take it in turns
so it's like squash against the wall
which was amazing i'd love to see that
turning into this game
ultimate frisbee ultimate isn't that i
like that it's an ultimate frisbee just
um
so much ultimate frisbee there is a game
version of it isn't it
ah what's that sports game uh that is
competitive frisbee
ah i know it's are you talking about um
like women jammers win germans that's
the one yeah oh windjammers
is that is that not um ultimate frisbee
no ultimate frisbee
it's a little bit am i correct me if i'm
wrong it's a little bit more like
football right in terms of
correct no yep that is correct
um oh hex hunter says
we should tell you about parachute did
you ever have the parachute
oh you you you all see that and you
throw it up and you run yeah
yeah yeah that was fun yeah parachutes
dealt
because the ultimate frisbee was one
where like you're trying to get to the
other side of the field and then
you have to throw it and you can only
take two steps once you catch it and
throw it again
and then people can intercept it and
then go the other way uh
pull us back one second pulse back one
more time push into 3v3 and we'll play
some 3v2s
okay keep everybody playing okay
nothing's so good
he's worth too soon the wildest thing is
like this is the perfect game for them
to reuse the ea big label and they just
didn't do it
yeah i'm not sure why
where i could see them if they ever
decided to bring back ssx
or nba street i wouldn't be surprised if
they just called it an era original at
this point
like this has so much ea big energy yeah
yeah
like you like this like i was mentioning
on uh to tim on kfc that like
i could see i could see a future where
ea's like yo those guys who made
shredders
they're dope with it let's just have
them make ssx and make it
original yeah something like that would
be super dope all right yeah me and mike
versus the three
okay let's see how that goes
oh don't you know where did you get this
haircut uh yesterday i got this haircut
looks great looks great i need to do it
let's get
um zach asks uh are you any good at this
game or not
no i i'm decent ah but i can't like it
sounds like an excuse but every time
anyone throws a ball my computer slows
down so
i can't stream and play a video game
that's not like an excuse yeah
this computer is not ready to be
streaming and uh
playing a game at the same time and
using discord
i can't wait for the overwatch stream on
thursday
yeah that's going to be uh that's going
to be interesting
i mean you guys decide while overwatch
cosplay oh hell yeah
out isn't it i think it just came out
why are we playing this then
we should be playing this is what we
should be playing right now you wish to
definitely be
sailing it up i don't have it downloaded
i wish you so many excuses
well i don't have the miller internet
anymore i have like
[ __ ] into what's not [ __ ] it's oh
okay i'll play sea of thieves review a
lot only for orange shaw burst though
the uh yeah the motion sickness is a lot
all right i've never played it's nice
it is fun let me know when you're
playing i'll play with you
i got an xbox series yes every time i
played
a blast let's do it we're blessing you
the best turn on your xbox we got this
i mean we get it pipe your feet in
and time and i'll watch if you guys want
to play sea of thieves
i bought an xbox series yes before um uh
e3 started and then i forgot that i
bought it
and uh it's just
in the box oh okay and then the other
day i was like oh [ __ ] i've got an xbox
series
so i need to only set that up and play
some thieves on it
you buying it was oh blessing
i think that was your own teammate i
don't think that's me oh
how do you unprime a ball throw
uh sprint so l3 oh
okay that's usually how i do it i'm sure
there's probably a more official way but
oh [ __ ] i forgot who was who there
oh good good
i'm really not paying attention yeah i
mean
tam when he bought that series s the
conversation was issued like we're
playing overwatch
and he went should i buy an egg a series
s
and then ah that was on me and then
we played around and before anyone
really had answered him he just went i
bought a series s
so yeah ballin
the towel should
uh i'm in the uk and i was like i'm
going to stream
um from i want to stream a bit more more
xbox games and i just didn't have
i couldn't be bothered to pick up my
series x from behind i was going to see
this [ __ ]
and bring it over each time so i was
like the smart thing to do is
solve this problem with money yeah
exactly
all right i'm gonna try and focus a bit
and see if i can actually get some kills
the thing that got me to buy uh an xbox
one back in the day
was both a price error at target
and scale bound being announced
yeah scale bound never got that game
yeah i was really excited for scale down
i was like oh
oh shoot a reason to buy a series uh
xbox one
i love platinum games and this dragon
guy seems cool i love [ __ ]
this guy with his his dr dre beats
headphones
look it's so cool like skill down look
like the coolest game ever
and now i'll come to accept that
platinum is a studio that i can't i
can't trust anymore
it's like yeah you never know which
platinum yeah you like
yeah it's like a possibility i i wish
i'd uh
i'd been recording when they said that
scarlet nexus not scarlet nexus jesus
christ uh
would you call it babylon's four was a
live service game so i've never seen
time look so sad
oh man it was it was devastating i
remember letting out
like a pain to scream you did
[Applause]
um you know he played scalebound it was
like
i let out the same noise that superman
makes at the start of the snyder cut
where he's getting killed and he's
sending like ripples of
of like scream out into the world that
was me
when they announced that's a live
service game
for me for me it was it was even before
they said that it was remember watching
the game play
and it's halfway through it i like i was
like this game
or no i was like this this is less
exciting to me than i would have thought
i think michael and i was like yeah this
is not doing it
and then we got to the live service
stuff and i was like all right well it
was nice while it lasted i guess
why have i lost it oh my god
yeah in a weird in a weird uh alternate
reality where
platinum had no l's they probably would
be my favorite game studio
what is your favorite game studio
insomniac
lucy it's a bomb i don't know what time
it was a bomb
i don't know what i'm doing
except for that that can i get a few
frames per second please
i can have a few frames as a treat ah
once upon a time i would have been my
favorite game studio
to win the match especially during the
ps2 era they're up there
let me alone state of immigration
how much do you emergency big time bro
midnight club
god damn oh my god wait
table tennis oh my god how do we lose
that
the strength
yeah i love that one ooh mike's got that
mvp
uh we played well we were doing it up he
killed it what the hell are you doing
in there but blessing what's going on
with your character
oh i'm just laughing i'm just like
you're vibing don't worry about it
a couple more donations uh so be on the
xbox chat we are raising money for april
gamers uh tinyurl.com
playford2021 if you have a few dollars
to spare it will go towards an amazing
cause
uh twenty dollars from anonymous thank
you so much and fifty dollars from zach
ryan
he says thanks babe i was uh that was a
michael impression for your blessing did
you enjoy it
wait i missed it was the michael
does he don't do that anymore i think he
does every now and then
i've heard him i said these are some
marrow thing and i'll just say anytime
anytime
he makes a decent mirror prince i'm like
yeah that's michael right there anytime
he says susio yeah
are you doing me and lucy versus the
three yeah all right
hell yeah okay all right lucy you
prepared you ready
uh prepared for you too carry me
it's all about the teamwork and i'll be
playing all these we're gonna pass back
and forth we're gonna stick together
we're gonna pick our shots we're gonna
catch the balls
try everything ball whisperers is what
they call us and we're going to lose
no i'm pretty sure it was the ball
handlers
lucy and bless the ball whisperers
[Laughter]
oh come on i definitely caught that
damn it it wasn't fast enough oh wait
oh you still fell off i like hit the
button in it
hitch for a second so here again
oh my god oh my god
oh slogan now if you're watching fx show
on hulu
is fearless and
i was making fun of it the other day
because i'm like what is that
out here doing that's fearless green
lighting shows from little dicky and
childish gambino
oh yeah perfect i am so excited for
season two of uh
of dave though okay dude i watched my
first job already is so good
wait is it out yeah oh yeah oh
my god and i'm here in the oh wait
oh oh i was going to ask what to do
there but so i just needed him off the
circle
and that seems to have done it yeah this
map perfectly this map is too much for
my computer
it's having a bad time um time i'll tell
you what i
actually did turn my settings down i'm
mine are on the lowest
oh well i don't know how to help you
but i appreciate you i didn't oh
oh my god
how do you see me up here
oh it's really fun to eat people off the
lap
yeah thanks for having a field day over
here
oh are you seeing michael
i see uh greg's up to the right as well
hi greg
hi what oh no he got me
oh oh wait oh
oh my god this okay i can't
i can't go near anything that's got like
changing lighting otherwise my frame
rate just
dips oh it's you
i thought you stood your friend right my
friend and i was like what
it's more expensive
oh good catch annoyingly good catch
oh my god i can't see anything
dude hello all right where are they at
they're up there where are you at though
uh i still mike was up
on this wait
are they around here oh my god where are
you at
oh
i'm an entanglement right now greg
you can also if they're balled up you
can also throw a ball at them while
they're in that form
it's like a nice way to get it now loose
go away
wait how did you survive that oh okay i
didn't i mean i didn't have it didn't
have it i didn't have stuff
i didn't have it in me oh my god
oh it was the two
oh man good job
what goal team good
damn it loose
she's gonna get me
some play with this greg
dude lucy's holding it down i've learned
over time
tim would you say your favorite studios
from software yeah
they're the only studio that makes good
games
it's fair it's very fair
[Laughter]
everyone's like everyone else's trash
for baby games
like consumer production is also very
good
insomniac so very good if you count you
count conjuring productions
is metal gear as well yeah if you count
consumer productions as metal gear then
yeah
all right they're very good insomniacs
great
capcom surprisingly good you know they
put out a lot
oh come on
the lines then
oh my god oh
no i got you i got you
yes no mike no no
oh oh oh no
ah great catch time great catch i don't
know how i did it
i just have to i just have to spam it
and hope for the best
capcom new new lost planet win
never give me a new last point never it
was the game i was playing recently
where i was like this is basically lost
playing it i forget what game that was
was it might have been our outriders
girls they could have called this game
oh my lucy
oh hi daniel mourinho daniel says he's
very into this music
it's good in it it's got like huge uh
jet set jet grind radio future
energy it's got big like sega energy
it also kind of reminds me of like the
music gorillas would make
like you can imagine gorillas over the
top of this
i did so i didn't realize that gorillas
had like their own
like lore yeah
i didn't i don't know i just thought
they were like fun animated
guys and gals
gosh god damn it i hate this game
nice uh oh yeah lucy oftentimes if we're
in a two-in-one situation
i'll pass to you take it from there
oh my god i can't i couldn't
what is this game doing
please stabilize
oh damn it how is blessing still
standing
this is famous first god had him and
he's not even flinching
good dad oh my god no
get him nice yeah here we go all right
this is close
that took a lot of energy to take down
just one person
you can follow up and then i'm going to
charge you up and then 30 in the air and
i'll turn you into a bomb
and then you can aim when you land and
try and land on them
uh no okay i missed that but
okay that was a good trick so we're
doing the same thing you just gotta run
out of the way
okay uh yeah
oh hi greg all right what's up bud
oh oh god
okay he's down to one
there's time
seconds remaining stop it
got it it's all tied up
oh
live to see another day squad good job
right
all tied up
that's music is good though uh jake asks
how asks how's everyone doing i'd be
doing better if you donated to
tinyurl.com2021 that's how i'm doing
jake get the money out
help someone jake i'm pretty good let me
out
only if you can of course and if you
can't then um
please share the stream and maybe you
will be sharing it with someone who can
oh my god i hate blessing with such
fashion
oh good catch mike oh man that was good
man that was energy
oh my goodness god blessing no say mlg
no only you say it oh it's mlg no thing
anymore what the hell did that come from
is
no
greg
eat them
damn where does naughty dog fall for you
in that conversation okay
they're all right grab might grab mike
you did great time
i like most of their games i think some
of them are overrated
yeah damn just just the introduction
because
how spicy did this dream want to get i
mean if you i if you ask me
say tell me which ones are overrated and
i'll tell you which one it is
ask me it's up to you which one's
overrated
it's the last of us too
okay damn he said it
i said it i meant it i said it i said it
with my chest i said it with my chest
tam uh chasmatazz in youtube chat says
sup tomorrow
uh long way from leighton sixth form
caz has chaz miller
caz that's where i went i went for
for uh college but the name kaz isn't
ringing a bell
but then i have a terrible memory these
days caz
i'm sure i do know you but i mean that
is also that user
like that yeah true i'm i'm an old old
man now
but damn lay in sixth form it's a blast
from the past
ah just admit you got too big for your
bushes all right that you you
you forgot i moved i moved to america
and i was like forget everything
just save over all this information
throughout you coward
oh no lesson help me
i'm trying my best there we go gold team
ggs hate to see you you're a very
amazing teammate thank you
thank you thank you for your service
you're incredible you told me so much
yeah is there only one
game that we've had where someone other
than blessing has been mvp
yeah only only mike hey michael yeah
that was when we were yeah together
oh man i'm sweating i can't remember who
cassidy's now
i feel like i've already thrown you off
yeah
uh oh wait
what they talk about in chat oh so when
we talk about gorillas they were saying
that like daft punk is better did death
punk had like a
have law yeah they had
because there was a movie right there
what was it called interstellar
um something something something
interstellar something something
something
six six six six six four nine i don't
know
six nine in an interstellar 69
hell yeah yeah you've seen that it's in
that video
cass is now rustling anymore because
they say lol don't worry enjoy your
reviews on gamespot
what so they enjoy your videos and games
on broadcasting
wow i don't really care honestly
i'll try to get a 3v1 going yeah go on
yeah i'll see what they can do
yeah get over on that side come on come
on yeah bring it to them
uh please keep donating if you can
tinyurl.com
playful2021 raising money for ablegamers
it's not letting us buy
mike you gotta go somewhere is there a
button for us to press actually you know
what i just won't move you have to go
no i can't i can't unless somebody has
like an override
no um are you ready and up yeah
everyone's ready to go
yeah time time i'll go and i'll just
stand i'll just stand blessed don't
worry
how do we do it with the dev that one
time
they probably weren't leader
so everybody behind your best behavior
don't hit
in city hall okay what is mike are you
just spectating
it's just gonna be dead stick yeah he's
gonna be afk uh
muhammad abdu says tam where is your
reaction to the new trailer
of the new from software game where is
my reaction
i don't know we weren't recording my
reaction weren't we we need to
take it i've been waiting screenshots
yeah i've been telling everyone we need
to steal some ideas from kind of funny
and do like live reacts but no one's
listening to me
they're like kind of funny he's
perfected it we can't do it any better
it's like
god are you kidding me blessings he
takes the lead
catches every ball in the multiball all
right all right
he called what oh
ah you're lucky i've got a hitch mate
a hitch
i think chad can probably oh scheme can
probably see it it's like freezing every
other second
there you go how do i get up
i fell i heard it i've fallen and i
can't get up
how do i recover i want to
walk into the sea
okay oh nice
thank you oh game informers rating
gaming former hell yeah
oh sorry i'm like i didn't know social
he's over here he sucks
catching all the balls
how did he this is this is how he
trained
he just tells all of his friends to come
in a private lobby and just three i want
him all the time
i just caught three in a row and i feel
like a god so this is what it feels like
to be a blessing
ah nice the tine one
faked out okay okay
there he is he's coming back
i can have your ball please over to that
side yes of course thank you
[Laughter]
my ball mule
oh he's going off to the other side he's
going to be over here cone of safety
this is me luring you away from snow
michael michael
i'm giving them balls i'm only helping
more point to them the round multiball
i'm blessing you you've played too much
of this you need to stop i know i do you
need to stop man it's honestly a problem
right where did greg go
somewhere at the door he's gonna come
back dressed in like
a character as a pirate yeah yeah
as captain jack sparrow
give it a rest blessing you're trying
too hard
i did just get guilty of strive so i
plan to start playing that more instead
of this
yeah i need to i need to get into that
i don't i don't know if you're if you're
trying to play
we're going to have ping issues but
we'll make it work
oh yeah we'll make it work i'm wired in
oh thank you
look leo no control said i don't know
how this game works but for me lucy is
the best player so
that's what makes you think how did you
not how did you not get got by that that
was
i sorry blessed it i got actually angry
that you're too skilled phil stop
it where are you look at it
he's getting mad at me
because he's too good
aren't you seeing a human blessing in
aegis
he's right in front of you so right here
oh my god
he's oh no
oh it's funny thanks mate
alex what's up alex yeah alex have a
great stream thank you
oh come on oh
blessing blessing
big head isaac said don't give in to
pressure bless hone your craft
so good at the skin advice
yes come here mike you like that
oh what oh whatever
nice yes okay okay
oh boy what's happening tim what are you
doing to michael nothing don't worry
about it yeah we might
we might be colluding against blessing
oh
there's having a nice mike technically
didn't do anything i just threw him at
you
he's innocent
oh who did i catch oh multi-ball
oh god oh god oh oh my god what
figured it out they figured it out oh no
this this just became 4v1
i don't know if i can handle this
i feel alive oh don't fall down oh my
god
don't i fell it's all
tired i'm sorry i keep falling like a
fall and i can't get up
if you're watching this we're raising
money for uh ablegamers an amazing
charity
and their mission is so that everyone
can game uh if you've got a few
dollars to throw their way uh the donate
link is on screen now it's in the
description box
tinyurl.com playful2021 and we'd really
appreciate it and we'll obviously
read our donations we've got to figure
out some incentives for this
next 15 donation gets to uh create the
the parents of who
is up against bless
sorry bless i'm nominating you for this
because you are the best player oh it's
all good
oh what oh my god
i got caught by the camera
do we want to invite we can ask simon
carty if he wants to play
cardi if you're watching get in
give us all your money and get in it
cost you 50 buying cardy
i just wasted three of those balls there
oh wow uh necromancer said how about a
play blindfold for one minute
oh my god so i was uh during practice
when
i was um throwing the ball at the
mannequin thing that throws back i was
trying to see how long he can go
catching it with the perfect cast
without actually looking at the screen
because the sound queues in this game
are incredible yeah i think it's
a very doable thing to play this game
without division
i like it i like it 15
and we will try the just by sound
[Music]
it's taking three of us to beat one
blessing
barely beat him i feel
alive now you finally feel something
i mean i don't stand a chance when you
guys coordinate your shots when you guys
are going at me
up at once i mean that's the secret that
we have we're not
coordinating because you're on the line
and you would hear us coordinate i'm
playing metal gear
knockout city here be hiding under a box
oh i'm playing stuff
gold team takes the lead that's fair
i didn't think you saw me
kidding me
there he is
oh
drain balls on them the only way
absolutely disgusting
wish fire
rain fire wow was that a victor resnick
reference
no that was a thanos restaurant avengers
come on
no rain rain fire is uh
yells
oh blessing what are you doing
there we go finally christ
uh nato x asks uh is gdc known for big
reveals like e3 i'm wondering what the
chances are
that we'll see anything from uh
microsoft and nintendo that weren't
shown at e3
probably not um probably no because it
generally isn't the main biggest thing
right yeah
it's not big like you're talking right
now yeah it used to be a thing but like
a very specific thing however if you
revealed a little big planet and sing
star and phil harrison was talking about
uh
play 2.0 3.0 whatever it was but if you
tune in you can gd see these nuts
oh my god wow oh wow ladies and
gentlemen doesn't that deserve
a five dollar donation right now go
ahead and hit it
tiny url
i don't know what i want you good i got
you
i got you yeah uh zach in all caps just
said
boo
what in the world one more
this is a new strategy
[Music]
give me the call to natalya
oh my god not you
bless it i didn't mean for you to pass
to me
i just saw lucy's body in the distance
look i'm doing great
why not pay attention
mike what are you doing i can just every
so often see you in the sidelines
dancing i'm actually watching i'm
enjoying it i'm also
figuring out the flying mechanics here
looks like they've done a little bit up
with the uh the updraft over here on the
wind side so that's nice
i'm just hanging out uh
blessing can go three on one with no
problems here very impressive
no no problems we're giving him
trouble giving him a little trouble or i
don't like that i can't really see it
cause i'm trying to remember
that i like that lie you're telling
yourself
hey guys hey guys look at the score
right now
oh reverse right i guess i guess it's
yours like that's 9
he just said um blue team is catching up
i thought he said lucy is catching up i
was like yeah i'm doing it
damn we could have won that by taking
mike out very quickly
oh got a donation twenty dollars from
wasted bandwidth
uh thank you very much hey and i hope it
was because
of the deeznutz joke yeah you think i
won't do that on the charity stream i'll
absolutely do that on the entire stream
look i would be i would be disappointed
if you didn't
they don't change yourself for anybody
all right all right let's swap me out
let's swap me out for a snow bike mic
all right go back into 2v2 okay you want
to go
yeah yeah if you guys want to tv to each
other i could also sit out
oh oh my god what's going on how do i
get back to the moment i kind of want to
see what blessing is going to do to
just kids out there like i think you
should we should make is it still
three the most you can have enough party
or whatever or is it for
i think you guys can do four uh league
play i'd step out and
i'll step out and just hang out if you
guys want to go in there and like tear
it up in a real thing
just go out there in the streets see
what happens i've asked cardi
if he wants to play
it's probably better if i step out
because i'm like my my network is not
having a good time with this
but then what are you going to show
aren't you showing the game expectation
okay noise
i hate how that dummy is really good at
catching okay
so what we want to do is uh what is it
street play
street play
okay so does someone want to drop off
then
oh drop out of the game yeah i can do it
okay
there you go he's gone
yeah this soundtrack is fantastic this i
mean the soundtrack also has ea big
energy yeah i feel like i want a b-boy
to this track right now
like i i would oh what we're doing
oh wait we play with other people
what's going on here oh we're playing
against other people yeah
big pet isaac says uh beat those dumb
kids so
let's let's be off some kids all right
let's work together stick together it's
not extra life yet so we can beat up
some kids
but when extra life comes around we go
uh right now we're facing a crew called
balls of fury very good very good
i'm not going to read that last one
daniel moreno comes up with a great
point that like
the ragdoll animations when you're
flying off screen should have the wasted
yeah oh yeah that would be very good
another reason why rockstar are one of
the best devs in the game
their influence is felt everywhere
nobody's had a death sequence like
rockstar
wasted
wow look at these customizations there's
only three of them though
one kid quit out like right at the last
moment he saw a blessing
the popsicle is part of the heat wave so
you're supposed to collect those
and then you'll get uh you'll get tokens
for the heatwave events
neat oh well this is gonna distract me
okay i'm with tim
yeah my i'm collecting all the popsies
my internet's having a bad time that's
another time we just found out they're
all over the map
all right um lucy i'm with you
trying to find a ball
oh no
i love that there is a dedicated button
just to say the phrase ball up oh
i don't know what it means but it sounds
rude
oh thank you
we catch that
oh can i get up
oh no
what
[Music]
oh come on
okay this team is sweaty you didn't need
to hear
gold teams falling way behind
yeah you did you apparently did because
you needed to kick in the ass to get out
there and be better you know oh my god
i need a ball yeah i'm spending most of
my time looking for a ball
right now yeah this map has
no balls yeah i'm gonna pass if i see
you i'm gonna pass you
i'm with tim i'm also being distracted
getting these ice lollies
that's a way better turn than possible
do you not have that
yeah nice no we don't call it oh god no
yeah i'm trying to get inside while over
here
let's go that is slowly son yeah
actually it's got a good mouth feel
yeah popsicle doesn't have good
mouthfeel to me
it also makes sense like i like the idea
of calling it an
ice lollipop which is basically what yes
i've never thought of popsicles in that
way oh
no they boot me off i thought i did a
jump there but obviously not
oh uh made it mad explosion says use
each other as balls
yeah that's always an option if you
can't get a ball by somebody
don't mind me
okay i was too busy being a bull and
then they um
good try i think i grabbed almost all
the ice lollies off the map
i'm one away
about that greg miller you gotta get the
next game get yourself some of these
i gotta get some of these ice blocks
they got some good stuff in the shop you
can get with them
they look really tasty as well i kind of
want one
they do look appetizing yeah it looks
like a strawberry and lemonade one
yeah maybe raspberry lemonade too oh
run away run away no
gold team uh necromancer asks what would
be a weird popsicle flavor
i'll start mac and cheese baby vomit
oh wow okay i was gonna say mashed
potatoes and gravy but you took it to
baby vomit right off the bat
go home go home do you not think that
gravy would be a good one though
just like a thing of gravy a savory
savory popsicle no um
i don't want anything that's ice cold
gravy
like cold wet and salty isn't it good
yeah comedy
and that's not the combination
that's what she said
some people are into dead people you
know
oh no bro what no
uh plus i'm is that your dead body
yeah i'm dead cold then wet or whatever
oh go on oh i found another ice block
tim i'm here with you how many
icelanders you got now mike
i i think man they keep showing up on
the map greg you'd be
you'd be kind of blown away there's a
lot of them they just keeps respawning
from them i bet you're like the game is
well i found another
passing charges up the ball is like
crazy okay
we'll see where you can pass the more
you're going to be in a position to
the ice lollies rewards you with tickets
that you redeem
yeah it's like 100 ice lollies for one
ticket or something like that
uh we're in the construction site the
broke down school
i believe is what this map that's
concussion yard if you get
all 17 ice pops in concussion yard
you'll get
60 60 60 tickets
oh wow then i'll be almost ready okay
hold up let's not win real quick i gotta
forgot to get this one over here
wait what uh our win isn't guaranteed
blessing
yeah we are only in the lead by one
point plus
let's not start looking for icelandic
right now taking over right now
uh wait wait wait wait what did what did
tickets get you
prizes yeah there is a special heat wave
like a
cosmetic thing going on in the shops all
right they got a cool like uh
jack-in-the-box logo they got a cool
outfit they got some
suntan lotion for your face i like this
ice cream truck glider that might be the
one
i love that one that's 65 right after
that
yeah that's just the game that's not bad
mvp
river rider uh mike that's what i want
easy river rider looks like you in that
photo man dragging that inner tube
nice absolutely sent it you need 65
tickets for that okay i'm gonna need two
games
damn lucy now that they've added a cross
play to overwatch
yeah when are we getting the crew back
together yeah we're
here for you stop playing local city and
we'll be there
he's he's got a point there oh cardi is
playing
knockout city now oh you wanna add him
he's not here playing with us um
i guess time you'll have to be a group
leader again and add
it's all tied up
over here opposite side oh yeah i see
him
oh yeah oh god
mike uh i invited old simcard to my
group so
i can invite you all
[Music]
oh
i did get an achievement though
a steam achievement so what's even the
point am i right exactly nobody cares
it's like bitcoin
needs one more point to win i wish my
steam achievements were the same as
bitcoin
oh the sound that you make when you pick
it up is a crunching sound which doesn't
sound a lot like an ice lolly
well if you're one of those mad lads who
bites you bite into it yeah there's an
invisible ice lolly on my screen
like it's transparent like you're not on
indiegogo 64 when you're playing as the
wrong kong
yeah you can't pick up the item yes
when did they get a fourth unbelievable
ridiculous yeah unbelievable matt man
pro
thank you to duncan for the 20 um if
you're watching along at home and you're
having fun and you would like to donate
we're raising money for ablegamers
tinyurl.com slash play for all twenty
twenty one
we are at five thousand eight hundred
ninety five let's see if we can get to
six thousand by the time we're done
we've got just all under 20 minutes
let's see
come on folks all right i just joined
the
game over bragging's group yeah let me
just merge in the groups
and then duncan has also just donated an
extra thirty dollars so thank you
duncan knows what's up duncan knows not
good news
okay i'm in
am i in did you just merge
is everyone here now yeah
that's how easy it is in knockout city
wow
just as easy
simon's hair party cardi
there he is right here he's in
tron he's here we're playing we're
playing catch with him
oh look at my sick jacket i got the kind
of funny jacket
you joined the crew lady yeah you're on
the crew now
i'm family
oh blessings we're family
i can't believe i paid for this game yet
again
gamespot doesn't support developers you
know
um all right unbelievable
how much does simon play this game uh i
think he's played it one and a half
times
wow okay he ragequitted
[Laughter]
how do we get cardi's voice in game chat
no no no no please don't enjoy the
discord
i'm begging you well join discord video
off and then you just hide non-partisan
video participants you're fine tim i
don't want to risk it man i don't want
to risk
[Laughter]
that's in our contract i mean
so what have i been doing these past two
and a half years
an illicit affair that was you were you
were undercover
oh my god
well he's still a nigerian voice no he's
not
he is not over there he's pushing a
broom
don't touch anything he's phoning in
he's spending his days
making sandwiches on the subway website
uh zach says not yet tammy well he's
full named you there oh no
that's mad
it's like getting scolded by an older
brother cam you
i don't know what samuel
uh we're at eighty dollars in open world
video game oh say that you can go to
hell
you go to hell so tammuel sounds like a
fantasy open world
yeah it's like one of the joke
characters yeah
it's like an uh an a a part of tamriel
oh yeah that's what i'm thinking of yeah
but it's also like the you know the dumb
like drunken character in a rockstar
game
have you seen my mate samuel he's been
gone for three years
time uh i need a new
gta yeah i could do
et online to come out to next gen like
now i can't i can't wait to get back
into it
now you can play that now on a pc
yeah but i want to play on a ps5 you can
put a ps5 controller
you can put a ps5 controller in pc yeah
but it won't have the
hd rumble that's the wrong oh you have
to have
feedback all the things that sony's
trained me to say one more point
[Laughter]
what in the world oh and also i have my
i have my fingers crossed hey we made it
to 6 000.
blessing was not only in the middle of
talking he had his fingers crossed and
had to uncross his fingers to clap
and he was like oh god uh
darth michaelski with 75
in there legend thank you so much
absolute hero legend this is how much
i'm into the game is when you said we
made it i think you meant like we won
i mean your team did correct yeah oh my
god
i found the deceased body of tamul yeah
wait what i was going to say earlier is
that i i really hope that with the new
uh next gen version of gta online that
they fix
the services and how long it takes for
matchmaking
oh yeah so that it can finally be well
they well they had that there was a
story right about that guy who was like
hey i found this line of code that is
making all of your
your entire game run like ass all you
gotta do is delete this line and they
were like oh okay
yes yeah and they gave him like they
only gave me 10 grand for that right
i want to give him my job something like
that yeah yeah
oh way behind oh i would have given that
assist
yeah the nintendo strategy you mean
the nintendo switch
yeah hey seasoned assist and if you ever
stream any of our games ever again
you're dead
danny mourinho says tam's restraint for
not playing valorent right now with the
new update is quite incredible
yeah i'm just waiting i'm i was
genuinely thinking earlier i might
stream the new valerian update after
this
doesn't get on valerian mike young
valerian i heard you mike i heard you're
amazing of valor
yeah dude i'm really good with the judge
man let's go call me the uh
the guy right quality of the judge they
called you the guy
right there bro i'm the guy who usually
quits halfway through the match
who plays the judge and the guy who
plays the judge they call me judge
durian executioner like there was
there's a lot there you know it was a
lot i got dodgeball on the mind right
now
hey damn hit me up i'll play some
valerian i'm down yeah let's do it i
liked playing that one time we played
it's good man it's good i like i hear
you tim talk about it so much that i'm
like yeah i really want to play valorum
but i know
i would suck at it because i don't have
that counter-strike
training that's the thing that scares me
too is that i'm not
that kind of shooter person the closest
thing i played to a tactical shooter
would be rainbow six siege
you'll be fine i'm also very hardcore
but if you played siege you'll be into
it
yeah i don't know man it's scary it was
like
when you guys were teaching me how to
like stand still so your shots don't
scatter and all this stuff i was like
damn this seems
intense yeah i mean like i i got a new
level
i had andy and like various other people
helping me
can you ready up please blessing is this
your first time playing or what
oh i'm new to this game sorry
but also we can play overwatch yeah true
but also according to ign
and game spot no it's is it nine out of
ten for us
i think we gave it ten if it's a nine
you guys should maybe think about
bumping it up no we stick with uh with
our opinions
once we've made the decision we stick
with it on like ign
oh we don't damn we've re-reviewed we
reviewed
we're actively reviewing games
yeah we re-reviewed to see if these not
that long ago yeah yeah
i have re-reviewed many games i think we
gave out nine
i want to say yeah it was one by one
michael rujo i think it was it was
legend mike uh on our team
has this incredible minecraft server
that they've played in so much that it
has
law like there are companies in it
is incredible i've seen videos of the
casino
i don't know how he has the time to make
that stuff because he's also very busy
i'm like what are you doing yeah yeah i
always see him online on slack but then
i also hear about his great
escapade you are right he's never
looking directly into his camera in any
of our meetings
he's always just looking off to the
right
building it's like the loop here of saga
all over again yeah
i'll never live that down
ratted out by discord of all things
might get away from that car ah
oh my god
you're just using it as a mobile cover
sorry greg it's okay
you had your eyes on the ball
oh wow oh oh god uh thank you to al
tribesman
uh for a hundred dollars thank you al
tribe's been the predator
the predator hell yeah greg we should
play predator again remember predator
you should that was a joke uh
they put in new maps they put in all
sorts did they
yeah i'm actually down there i forget
what it is it's something like uh
four predators one human all right
something weird like that i forget what
it is
in that case i'm no longer joking okay
good
or or we wait until september or october
whatever month it comes out and play
uh some of that rainbow six extraction
oh
i can't wait or we just keep waiting for
back to the board oh yeah
back for blood
i'm scared for the fantasy draft
uh back for blood being the biggest
reason because i have that as my
counterpick
yeah and the closer closer you get to it
the more and more i'm like oh shoot that
might have been a mistake
yeah fanny's draft looking good right
now
oh yeah me and you are like like you're
you're definitely a
uh ahead and i think you have a better
looking lineup
but we're definitely close i think
a lot can happen we remember heroes can
come out and be a 10 out of 10 game who
knows
oh my god i pressed the
catch one as well and then like hitch
for a second and then i got hit in the
face
greg they're all over you i know i know
nothing to do mike nothing you can do
about it no not with three people
following you you tried
not when it's me blessing cardi this is
where
the the hours of overwatch come together
we might not be able to hear cardi and
he might not be able to hear us
but it's it's melding he's he's got he's
got the stream open you know he's got
the stream open
yeah his stream is going to be behind
i was fine he figures out
he's a smart boy where did you come
from where did you go where did
you come from i go
um never played down my heroes but i
i is that wait it's suda right yeah yeah
oh i'm in then it's fine travis
touchdown baby i was touched down
we heard suda in for an episode of
audio logs where he basically did a sort
of his
his entire career and i was
i was previously like unaware i've
played like a couple of his games
mike
not really aware of like how much of a
cult figure he is
oh yeah and he's made like a lot of
games yeah and just like how
wacky some of the games that he's made
on how great they are
killer is dead yeah put killer is dead
in there put uh
there's a game that's like it takes
place like a fantasy
um fairy tale kind of world like oh
um alice in wonderland type stuff
he'll release 51 games and then put it
out as a suitor collection
oh yeah i'd love that wait that was the
thing he did right
did he he did something like that that
sounds like some kind of nonsense that
he would do so
i'm not surprised
or maybe i'm thinking i might be
thinking of um normal heroes
kind of stretch man because he had a lot
of
weird indie game times yeah yeah
oh hi greg hello
you were all over there huh just
chilling out um
coordinating yeah please please
that was for you chat you all saw
tied that i've been trying to
once i've been cardi about um trying to
figure out an audio solution
that doesn't wreck the discord um
and he said it's fine i don't need it
i'll just play and win help me
there we go here we go
because of my internet connection i have
to play stealth
i gotta play patient that's just how you
play
games i know you're behind me oh oh
shoot
oh you got team needs one more point to
win the round
oh oh how did you catch that
there's so much focusing going on
it's time to take the gloves off lucy i
know you've been holding back for the
last round but let's let's actually take
gloves off
okay okay okay this is it this is this
is obviously game
point but this is like last round
probably right yeah probably yeah
okay dodgeball is live
oh mate i am so excited for season two i
you guys you guys watched ted lasso yeah
oh yeah yeah
oh my god blessing are you seeing that
lasso
that's one day you can watch all of it
yeah if you if you get the week-long
trial you can you can smash that
i watched it all in one day and it was
like a comfortable watch
10. it's like 10 20 minutes
and it's a feel good watch as well it's
the only show that i've finished and
then immediately
restarted yeah same hair yeah wow it's
really good man
and you don't like need to know anything
about british football or anything like
that
wait british football meeting soccer
yeah yes
oh yeah
oh nice job blue game all right guys
just split it apart
yeah we need to coordinate
okay
party and i coming in oh my god
[Music]
dude i was playing metal gear solid on
monday for the stream of
jake baldino and now i'm just like i
might just replay mega solid
over again hell yeah
we're just uh on one of our post shows
for kfc
we're talking about the best video
kadema games
and we got to the part where we're
ranking the metal gears
and i kind of gave i came down to the
place where i was like i could rank
these in any order and i would be fine
with it like they're all just pineapples
yeah they are great
i can't even rank them at this point
like even though you're solid five i'm
like on the right day this is my number
two
dude mango solid five is the best
stealth action game ever created
oh oh yeah one thousand easy
easy clap yeah
good job blue team yeah we did it
that's it oh my god
wait who got mvp time going let's go
damn dream issues my
with the big x in front of it the entire
time flashing in and out and i was like
oh god
please hold i think that's it i think
that's all the time we can spare for it
so now we've got five minutes to kill
and we're just gonna do that by uh just
you know kicking it for a bit
and uh thanking everyone rappers that
are live they are live
oh my god pusha t uh
kendrick lamar uh
right to five nine uh logic
oh wow uh really
i don't know i don't know i like this
list this is that's personality
i don't know i need a full list i'm
missing one but i can't i don't know who
i'd say you usually don't hear logic in
the same list as pusha t and kendrick
lamar if you like
uh i like voice the five nine i need one
more rapper greg give me one more rapper
san francisco native right so are you
excited that logic
was that la okay you excited now that
logic is out
of his one year retirement no not in the
last slightest i don't i don't really
care about logic that much
uh i just said his name because it's the
first one that came to mind
anyways thank you guys for joining us uh
super super appreciate it remember folks
that you can
go to tinyurl.com for slash profile 2021
round of applause for the kind of funny
team
thank you thank you folks for hanging
out thank you for spoiling and obviously
the kind of funny best friends coming
through as well
uh saw a bunch of them in the chat as
always one of the best communities for
gaming on the internet
not even for gaming for anything and so
very very happy that we could bring
your crew and our crew together to make
sweet sweet cherry
sweet sweet content but yeah we're gonna
be streaming every day
uh for the rest of this week twice a day
lucy who have we got tomorrow putting
you on the spot
uh we have steve's phone tomorrow uh
10am until
12. and then in the afternoon we have
pro zed yeah yeah quiz
uh thursday we've got resident knievel
so we've got mike mccarty mary kish
and special guest uh lady matress
herself maggie robertson
and then we've got andy cortez joel
rubin james williams and blaine gibson
aka some folks that sometimes we play
overwatch with
yeah and we always joke when we play
that we are gonna go pro
but we kind of we usually rack up the
l's
so it's gonna be a fun one it's gonna be
a fun one um
and then on friday to top it all off we
have a big stream with our friends at
giant bomb and we still don't know what
we're doing no but it'll be a good time
like i've seen i've seen the list
oh my god that's a good shout out that's
a really good shout out this is a good
shot
but let's hope jan can figure it out
because he's doing it
leaving the tech side to jail but yeah
so come back every day um
and you know while we're not on stream
obviously that link is live so you can
donate anytime
um please do we'd love to hit 30k like
we said earlier it's a reach for the
shoot for the moon kind of uh total but
as close to it as possible we'd love to
get
um yeah thank you everyone for watching
and once again thank you for the kind of
honey crew
um for coming through appreciate you all
thanks for having us guys
say bye everyone bye
bye everyone